Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Researchers at NVIDIA have been hitting it
out of the park lately, and this work is no
different.
This technique performs image translation,
which means that the input is an image of
our choice, and the output is the same image
with somewhat different semantics.
For instance, an image of a city can be translated
to a map of this city, or a daytime photo
or video can be converted to appear as if
it were shot during the night.
And throughout the video, you'll see so much
more of these exciting applications.
A typical way of accomplishing this is done
by using Generative Adversarial Networks.
This is a pair of neural networks where the
generator network creates new synthetic images
trying to fool a discriminator network which
learns to tell a fake, synthesized image from
a real one.
These two neural networks learn together,
where one tries to come up with better solutions
to fool the discriminator, where the discriminator
seeks to get better at telling forgeries from
the real photographs.
In the end, this rivalry makes both of them
get better and better and the final result
is an excellent technique to create convincing
image translations.
In this work, not two, but 6 of these networks
are being used, so make sure to have a look
at the paper for details.
There was an earlier work that was able to
perform image translation by leaning on a
novel cycle consistency constraint.
This means that we assume that the source
image can be translated to the target image
and then this target image can be translated
back to look exactly like the source.
This kinda means that these translations are
not arbitrary and are mathematically meaningful
operations.
Here, the new technique builds on a novel
assumption that there exists a latent space
in which the input and output images can both
coexist.
This latent space is basically an intuitive
and concise representation of some more complicated
data.
For instance, earlier, we experimented a bit
with fonts and had seen that even though the
theory of font design is not easy, we can
create a 2 dimensional latent space that encodes
simple properties like curvature that can
describe many many fonts in an intuitive manner.
Remarkably, with this new work, converting
dogs and cats into different breeds is also
a possibility.
Interestingly, it can also perform real to
synthetic image translation and vice versa.
So that means that it can create video game
footage from our real world videos, and even
more remarkably, convert video game footage
to real world video.
This is insanity, one of the craziest ideas
I've seen in a while.
Bravo.
And now, hold on to your papers because it
can also perform attribute-based image translation.
This means that for instance, we can grab
an image of a human face and transform the
model's hair to blonde, add sunglasses or
smiles to it at will.
A limitation of this technique is that training
is still non-trivial as it still relies on
generative adversarial networks, and it is
not yet clear whether there is a point to
which the training converges or not.
The source code of this project is also available.
Make sure to take a good look at the license
before doing anything because it is under
the creative commons non-commercial and no
derivatives license.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!